well please welcome back to the show i
still want to call you a drew crew it's
a lisa
thank you so much
i know i love it
we are og baby yeah
we go back we're thrilled because you're
going to bring your cosmic talents um
right there to people tv i'm so excited
for you aliza tell me about it thank you
so much i am so excited too so my love
like in my mind astrology and pop
culture sit right next to each other i
love them both so this show is the
fusion of that we are going to be
looking at celebrity charts so we're
looking at people like my king harry
styles aquarius king yes megan fox
machine gun kelly we need to know what's
going on there so we look at that you're
actually going to do my chart too and
we're going to put it on the website so
you can see that
but since you're here and you're reading
charts of the stars can we get your
cosmic take on some pop culture stories
yes of course let's hit it first up
people reports hbo max just released a
new two-part documentary all about
britney murphy take a look at this women
in hollywood are pressured enormously
she had lost an inordinate amount of
weight and she was dressing totally
differently
she said that's what i've been told if i
wanted to be considered as a leading
lady
during a little dip she was having he
came along
and i think that's where her judgment
was muddled
and she became prey
yeah this is a very complicated story
everyone's talking about i was just on
the cover of people magazines that's
right yeah and there's still so much
mystery
surrounding this now when you look at
her chart isn't is anything helpful in
there britney's chart is very riveting
it's really interesting because she was
born during a new moon in scorpio so
that means that the sun which represents
your identity how you illuminate how you
take up space and then also the moon
your emotional inner world is in the
sign that is associated with intensity
and passion and also secrets so i am not
surprised that all of these years later
we are still trying to figure out what
happened because that is really baked
into her birth chart i am curious about
this documentary i worked with brittany
actually we did a film together called
riding in cars with boys and we got very
close
she was a force she was a good friend
she was very empathic
extremely sensitive almost as if she
didn't have skin she could read a room
and start crying in a moment's notice
you know whether it was for work or
because she was sort of taking on
someone else's emotions she was a very
good kind person and it seems like
she just got caught up in something and
that was really when we lost touch so
i'm
eager to see it because the mystery is
haunting to us to see this beautiful
bright star
dim the lights yeah well said and
there's still so many unanswered
questions so yeah i'll be tuning in yeah
me too
all right well next up um
megan and harry people reports that
they've just taken a partnership on with
ethic a financial firm that helps people
invest in companies that do good now
this is important because we've got to
get it together on this planet so we can
remain here
this couple
why do they seem so united on all fronts
what is the astrological reasoning here
megan and harry are
karmically cosmically every single way
you could be connected these two are but
really this relationship is built on
healing
all of the signatures for healing and
for transformation and for change and
growth show up in the chart and we're
going to see that in every venture they
take on together because everything that
they want to do they want to do it from
really heart-led as someone who grew up
idolizing princess diana i got to meet
her when i was seven years old and she
was so important and meaningful to us
she showed people that people with you
know aids at that point were allowed to
be touched she fought for land mines she
changed the world
and to see
harry
in a healing place after what's happened
and she was taken away from us it is
healing i'm glad that there is goodness
there continuing on i have goosebumps me
too i
i'm so fascinated by them i'm so i'm so
glad they're doing such good with their
lives but i still don't understand how
they could have left the royal family
i'm sorry but my entire life i've had
that dream that one day the phone ring
and i'd be like i'm princess of genovia
i
you know i mean am my fantasy so the
fact that they left is so fascinating
but it's in their charts that this is
their mission in life right so i have to
tell you about their charts megan
introduces harry to things that he would
not have access to otherwise
she exposes insight about his family
about the world that he came from about
his mother that without her influence he
wouldn't have been able to see so it's
really very profound fascinating well i
think your show is going to be huge lisa
kelly celebrity astrology investigation
is available to watch on people's free
streamer people tv with new episodes
every tuesday
[Music]